[Music]  mr. and mrs. Pawley  yep you heard that right in a newly  released promo for Jersey Shore family  vacation part 2 the 38 year old DJ  appears to be tying the knot with a  special someone but take a closer look  and you'll see that that's an Elvis  impersonator conducting the ceremony and  based on the body types of the two  people at the altar  something tells us this might be a joke  but in March the reality star who has a  5 year old daughter Amma Bella confirmed  to ET that he was single now I'm even  more picky when I picked women to  actually meet her oh my mother like only  the certain ones will meet them that's  why I like I put my standards up higher  a lot higher now and he admitted dating  is tough it's just hard in general now  because you got to question their  motives and intentions it's hard dating  and generous why I'm single so you're  supposed to look first supposed to just  come so I'm hoping the habits  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]